welcome to the digital marketing
certified associate course whether you
wish to become job ready for digital
marketing or wish to add on digital
marketing to your skill set or wish to
learn and use digital marketing for your
business you've come to the right place
we have designed the dmca course to get
you industry ready in digital marketing
you will internalize the domains of
digital marketing master the digital
marketing tools learn to strategize and
manage digital marketing campaigns and
work on digital marketing projects and
get certified through 4 projects we will
give you the required hands-on
experience in digital marketing to get
job ready this course will help you
prepare for five certifications such as
OMC a Google Analytics Google Apps
Facebook and YouTube as the world relies
on digital communication the reach and
the response of digital marketing keeps
growing as people get online they
realize that they are able to connect to
a greater world become more efficient
and they consume more digital products
and access physical products that may
have never been available before because
of this businesses have seen the
opportunities online and have responded
by creating more campaigns to reach more
people and it is only estimated to grow
exponentially so that's the world
forecast but what about your business
most companies have a digital marketing
budget and are planning to increase that
budget over the next year in fact they
don't just plan on increasing the budget
a little bit the average increase is
nearly 20 percent the demand and
effectiveness of digital marketing have
created one of the fastest growing
industries in the world and there is a
significant lack of talent to fill this
need being a capable digital marketer
increases your demand and your value in
the mark
place more than traditional marketing
professionals today's digital marketers
have to grasp a wider landscape present
a number of specialized skills and are
able to make a greater impact in a
business's revenue and profitability and
for those skills employers are willing
to pay higher salaries are you ready to
take the next step in developing your
skills and career are you ready to
develop your company's digital marketing
assets and be the inspiration for a new
campaign if so then this program will
provide you with the essential building
blocks to get started and start
practicing in the digital marketing
industry let's get to it
what are you going to learn in this
course in this course you'll learn the
essential disciplines search engine
marketing social media pay-per-click
marketing conversion optimization web
analytics content marketing email
marketing and mobile marketing as you
learn the concepts of each discipline
you will also learn the tools associated
with each area be that Google Analytics
as one of the leading industry analytics
providers Google Ads Facebook and
YouTube learning how the tools work and
how to gain insights from those tools
will provide the feedback you need to
guide your work and clarify your
strategy in addition you'll know how to
create a digital marketing strategy from
evaluating your brand message to
targeting the right audience to receive
that message we'll look at how to
compare the many channels available to
marketers today and aside on not only
which ones to use but how to use each
one effectively then the course will
show you how to manage all of these
facets in a campaign planning resources
strategically communicating the right
message at the right time to the right
people
it takes planning and preparation to do
it right without planning I've seen too
many businesses get sidetracked and lose
focus only to lose profitability
creating a campaign plan and managing
the work on a schedule keeps you moving
in the right direction having a
measurement plan enables you to adjust
as necessary during the campaign and
make decisions that will enhance your
profitability uncover problems and find
new opportunities understanding how to
develop campaign milestones and
performance indicators keeps you on
course you will go hands-on in each of
the tools and perform assignments
designed to get you acclimated to the
tasks essential for operating in these
areas you will get familiar with the
basic operations of these tools how to
set up run manage and report your
results finally it's time to get
certified you'll be prepared to get
certified in one or more disciplines or
sit for your om CA exam an om CA a
certification
proves that you have been trained in
these high-value skills and are ready to
hit the ground running
[Music]